das thema mentale gesundheit ist für
mich ein herzensthema damit habe ich
mich jetzt ein ganzes jahr lang
beschäftigt schon vor corona waren
angstzustände oder angststörungen und
depressionen
eine der häufigsten erkrankungen in
deutschland und will krone hat sich das
ganze auch noch verschärft ich habe mich
jetzt ein jahr lang mit dem thema
beschäftigt weil ich selbst ein buch
geschrieben habe über meine persönlichen
angststörungen und panikattacken und wie
ich es geschafft habe da tatsächlich
raus zu kommen und in der zeit habe ich
mich ganz viel mit erwachsenen aber auch
mit kindern und mit familien unterhalten
und habe festgestellt was für ein
wahnsinnig großes thema das ist und was
mich massiv beschäftigt ist dass wir
sehenden auges eine generation
aufwachsen lassen die psychische
störungen aus dieser corona pandemie mit
leben beispielsweise weil sie ständig
masken tragen müssen weil sie zur schule
gehen konnten ihre freundin nicht sehen
können und egal welche ärzte kinderärzte
und kinderpsychologen man fragt sie
erzählen haben alle das gleiche das ist
wirklich massiv zugenommen hat und ich
möchte dafür einstehen dass wir das
thema mentale gesundheit viel mehr in
die öffentlichkeit bringen und dass wir
viel mehr darüber diskutieren und auch
viel mehr dafür tun dass es uns besser
geht und dass wir vor allen dingen auch
in den schulen so etwas wie ein
persönlichkeitsentwicklung unterricht
oder ein unterricht zum thema mentale
gesundheit einführen denn wenn wir die
kinder jetzt nicht auffangen was soll
dann mit ihnen passieren wenn sie
erwachsen sind ich habe das selber
erlebt wie man ein trauma mit sich mit
schleppen kann sein ganzes leben und
irgendwann bricht es über uns herein als
erwachsene und hat zum beispiel auch
noch mal zahlen rausgesucht menschen mit
einer angststörung gehen drei bis fünf
mal häufiger zum arzt oder werden
sechsmal häufiger wegen psychischer
erkrankung ins krankenhaus eingeliefert
als menschen die nicht an angststörungen
leiden und da frage ich mich was kommt
da auch auf unser gesundheitssystem zu
und können wir es wirklich zu lassen das
einfach so geschehen zu lassen so der
großer mut
hat sich nicht nur ein
großer mut sich dazu zu bekennen also
das für mich auch sehr ehrlich hier und
bin ganz gespannt auf dieses buch aber
wenn wir uns diese die schicksale der
kinder anschauen in der korona pandemie
dann müssen wir natürlich uns wirklich
selbstkritisch fragen habe alles getan
um den kindern da wirklich alles zu
erklären und auch wenn die in behüteten
umständen groß werden wir wissen es gibt
viele andere die die waren ganz ganz
haben ganz schwierige
familienverhältnisse zuvor gefunden auch
aber was ist mit diesen kindern jetzt
und wenn das zumindest ein impuls gibt
zu sagen okay wir müssen uns mehr um
unsere gesundheit auch mentale
gesundheit kümmern und müssen wege dahin
finden dann ist das gut nur das problem
ist ja dass es überhaupt nicht
ausreichend plätze gibt meint es gibt
statistiken du wirst sie kennt jeder
doch jeder vierte deutsche erkrankt im
laufe seines lebens irgendwann einmal an
einer psychischen erkrankung und muss
dann hilfe suchen nur diese
therapieplätze sind ja überhaupt nicht
absolut die frage ist was tun wir mit
den kindern wie vielleicht in dieser
situation und sind dann fahren wir doch
vielleicht wir unseren künftigen
gesundheitsminister werden wir ja
sowieso nicht beschäftigt habe aber die
jetzt sagen sie hat leider
aber die was auf jeden fall ein sehr
wichtiger punkt ist einstimmig ohne ein
geschenk zu wir unterrichten ja fast
alles also vom sport über uns aber wir
unterrichten nicht also kinder in
mentaler gesundheit also wie man dass
ich auf baut also was man zum beispiel
für also
gewohnheiten praktizieren sollte um also
wirklich selbstbewusstsein zu entwickeln
um mit krisen fertig zu werden und dass
das viel tatsächlich also ein schulfach
und würde an den enormen unterschied
machen und das ist auch etwas was also
leitende psychotherapeuten und
psychologen die in dem bereich forschen
alle fordern das ist definitiv etwas wo
man nachdenken müsste egal wer jetzt mal
gesundheitsminister oder was auch immer
wie lange müssen dann noch treffer
nachdem das ist also tatsächlich das ist
an der zeit ich aber ich stehe ja zu
indem sie und das
könnte jetzt also sagen dass also hätte
kommen müssen so was ist aber nach vorne
geblickt richtig gebrauchen ist es würde
sich übrigens auch massiv auszahlen das
wäre eine bessere lebensqualität für die
kinder es wäre mir gesundheit es wurde
alles für kinder leichter machen und
daher da machen wir zu wenig doch wo ich
widerspreche und zwar einfach weil die
studienlage das nicht hergibt muss man
der ehrlichkeit halber sagen wir wissen
zum derzeitigen zeitpunkt nicht und es
ist eher unwahrscheinlich dass das
tragen von masken die kinder psychisch
belastet was aber eine andere situation
wo das ausgeht alltag menschen sind
nicht selten die sagen was schlimm aber
es ist ein unterschied ob sich etwas
gehört habe was mir jemand gesagt
unterschätzen ein bisschen was das mit
den familien auch macht er aber es gibt
studien die sich damit beschäftigt haben
was für also entweder in der familie und
ich wurde dafür aber wir sind keine
kinder aber ich finde es wirklich
furchtbar um eine familie fans auf
sichtbar und nach nicht mehr und man
muss ja auch noch mal den ärztlichen der
erzförderung
einbringen gegenbeispiel also in einer
kultur in vielen asiatischen uns gefühlt
haben gegenbeispiel ist also in den
asiatischen ländern tragen die kinder
sehr häufig also in ihrer kindheit maske
zum beispiel um dem smog zu entgehen
aber auch bei kälte und
leiden darunter nicht ich will es aber
genau ich will ich will das auch nicht
in den vordergrund stehen aber was ganz
klar ist die kinder sind wir jetzt in
einer phase gewesen wo sie angst gehabt
haben weil eine sehr bedrohliche
erkrankung ihre eltern und ihre
großeltern und auch die kinder selbst
gefährdet was haben sie gefühlt mit herr
lauterbach nein das ist unfair das ist
nicht richtig die da in die angst ist
gekommen weil die krankheit da ist wir
haben versucht was uns auch gelungen ist
die zahl der menschen die an der
krankheit sterben so niedrig zu halten
wie möglich deutschland hat gemessen an
der ein so dass hier noch ganz lange
weiter diskutieren könnten aber ich habe
sorge dass es dann wieder zu heiß
hergehen
[Musik]